tonight is the People's Choice Awards
you on CBS and this is the show where
you the people not a bunch of Hollywood
insiders determine the winners that's
why we love it cuz it's like power to
the people everybody feels like they had
a hand in and tonight it's also about
the exes factor because some famous
former couples could be on this
collision course but one way or another
get ready for some fireworks super
secret there will be a lot of explosions
cannons host Joel McHale promises big
things for tonight's star packed show my
whole goal is not to screw up and we
have your first look at who is sitting
next to whom nominees Tom Hanks and
Kevin Hart are front and center
competing for favorite movie actor no
worries if Tom takes the prize kevin has
four other nominations also upfront
nominee jennifer lopez but we didn't see
a seat card for her rumored boyfriend
Drake okay yo need to get dun dun dun
dun at oracle he and his ex Rihanna are
the night's most nominated in music
they're each up for four awards and
they're competing against each other in
three of them XO Sarah Jessica Parker
and Robert Downey jr. are just one seat
away from each other the two dated for
seven years back in the 80s blake lively
is expected to attend but looks like
Ryan Reynolds may skip it maybe he'll be
home watching their two girls Jessica
Biel maybe on mommy duty during the show
no seat card for her of a Justin
Timberlake will be sitting close to his
friend Ellen and Ellen could make
history tonight she's already won 17
People's Choice Awards one more will set
a record and with three nominations
tonight it looks like she's got a darn
good chance he kind of want to know to
thank you
you